[Music]
of course Tom Brady said this after his
wife Giselle's comments Tom Brady said
sorry about my wife I don't know why I
put up with her oh wait yes I do she's
yeah Nicolas Cage Nicolas Cage tweeted
this to save time I've started seeing
yes two movies that haven't even been
written yet joe biden tweeted this joe
biden tweeted not gonna lie I've been
home in sweatpants since Thanksgiving I
don't think I've seen him around
yeah Chris Christie governor New Jersey
tweeted this just accidentally rolled my
assistant in cookie dough and swallowed
him whole he knew the risks how do you
accidentally roll simple and cookie
dough and eat them it's New Jersey oh
you're right Larry King you gotta love
Larry King Larry King tweeted this I
love all this tweeting it reminds me of
the morning when Birds evil
okay
apparently the whole process happened in
one more yeah the lizards are flying
next caller
Mitt Romney just tweeted this to the
poor of America I feel your pain wait
nope that's just a paper cut back to
eating money war Horace that's a big
movie War Horse just tweeted this was
just offered a part in a movie called
peace blue who's Bruce Jenner Bruce
Jenner tweeted this it's been raining in
Los Angeles luckily I just had my face
armor all that guy thinks ahead
Spencer Pratt tweeted this just because
you haven't heard from me doesn't mean
I'm not still a world-class douche bag
hashtag never forget
[Music]
and finally Rick Santorum tweeted this
three more primary wins I won't rest
until the entire electoral map is
covered in Santorum
[Applause]
my mother won't get it okay a frosty
combination of what haha
Andy why don't you do that why it sends
people to Google yeah very nice
you're right they need more money all
right here we go